foreign [Applause] Lafferty picks that off here's
Connor Timmons takes a look he's got Les Schwab
and fired that right on before the Leaf's power
play their second unit here comes out and right
over La Joie he tries to go upstairs first
onto the sidelines late in the season from
February 24th on Timmins just three games for the
Leafs as they went into playoff mode willinger to
the front and a nice stop there by hornberg he
drops down big tall guy right and then there's
Urban and just cruising on in he walks right into
the slot on his forehand back to the line Timmons
he sends it across Lafferty shot doesn't get to
the net and here's a jam play to the side and
poursford down to cover up pass rejected ricochets
to Sanderson and all rookie player last year down
low could check with room and petrazolia stick
on it still loosen fired out of the blue paint
by the Leafs close call Drew down low again and
can check tried to go between his legs to move
his brothers got down pat a loose but in front
Kentucky scores it's a power play goal for Ottawa
Morgan Riley and petrozelli did a really
nice job of thwarting the Ottawa Senators
on the first opportunity petrozelli doing
the rest that Ottawa regains control the
puck they get it up top but then it's a little
pass that goes into the middle to Bailey and
from Sanderson over to Giroud Giroud looks
like he's going to shoot it and then turns
the wrists over and slides it right over into
Bailey who's going to redirect this thing to
the net and of course who's there to pick up the
rebound you'll find out how to get his chances
and out came off the Stick of
the Notre Dame product Max Ellis
here come the Senators picked off and working in
sanderson's toe stop for the rebound cleared Away
by Riley thing that they know he's just gonna get
better and better after reading knowing when to
jump into the play and here he creates a great
offensive scoring chance he stepped into his
freshman year in the National Hockey League
remember he came out of North Dakota he had
that hand injury that plagued them all through the
summer in the training getting ready to play and
make it tough on the coaches to send
them back to Belleville so collab's
got it fires and petrozelli turns
that aside so over 20 shots now for
Ottawa here in the opening period Sanderson
across the cliff scores had a couple of really
good opportunities they continue to win the
battles for the pucks back to the point nice
rotation and then stutzler just uses Ellis as a
screen and snaps it right through and that's a
top end snapshot that petrozelli I don't even
NHL goal against the Maple Leafs [Applause]
once again from in tight period for
Jake Sanderson once again joining
the rush at the right time everyone
thinks he's going to the net with it
nope he knows highmore's driving in
there net Drive lays it out for him
but he believes there are tools to unlock at the
other end of the ice Place pandas who gets ready
for his second season in the NHL CJ snook already
declared that that's going to be the and general
manager Branch levig talked about getting to know
the younger players better Big Shot rebound and
forsberg across the Rob William nylander on the
doorstep there then gets to the foot of the net
here comes the shot and he knows he's coming
off after the puck on the far side and there's
Matt and Paulo the third pairing Force Ottawa
on the ice here and Lafferty and nice trying
to come up with the puck nice win support battle
timings across black as it scores high on foreign
you can kind of see this coming and it's been
four shifts now been more where the traffic has
been on the body good finish check on the puck
is nice he gets it out of the pile get it back
to the point and then let it all just breathe from
there and this doesn't happen you don't score that
goal without Gambrell cruising Right Through The
Eyes of forsberg I mean we mentioned sokoloff on
the first goal there the goal by stutes of their
second goal this here's a laser beam [Applause]
again
you're gonna get to know each
other this battle of Ontario
William nylander looking for the tires I had
trouble with it tied up but Drew's gonna win
that he may get the Rodman Rush down by two
here's Sanderson [Applause] Sanderson crashes
into the net the blender in there pulling
pucks out and how about this chance here
by Sanderson who's been declaring attempt
is knocked down and comes back to Timmons
again quickly across that's passed by herfit
and Steve Took a walk-in scores [Applause]
but now the game is Dead even Alex Steves with
the goal with just over two minutes to go in
the second period Buffalo five on three which
did not look good the Leafs come right back out
forget about it let it go it's gone you still
have time they do a nice job at getting set up
the pass back on the top of the seam and then
steams does a really good job of being patient
the fake slapper he draws it in a little bit
tighter to the hash marks where he has a fitter
a better look at the net he takes it away from
all the traffic and then it's gloves Sanderson
and Bailey Jake Sanderson stood slope
fire scores another short shot from
Dixon ottawa's regained the lead
do a real nice job here Josh Bailey
settles it down and then he hit scoots
were right across the the rink he's able
to tip it over to Chuck now the setups
in place Drew's going to cut through the
seam here it's going to be a little bit
of pitching catch with Sanderson and like
the Steve shot this is just a point-blank
shot here by stutzler this is him in
his office he loves shooting from here
but all those little things they add up
for the game and when people are upstairs
watching they take notices for Matthew Highmore
he's at a pretty good two period so far and a
third period to go and who knows what'll
come out of that 139 NHL game sealed by
ladder anything you don't already know but
a turnover and we saw this being the problem
soccer lock sends it back in and there
is Big Dennis Hill to beat six foot seven
and a shot brings off the boat a rebound
set wide but a chance for sokoloff if he
can finish this off you have no idea what
that means to a guy like soccer off moving
forward and everyone had 11 with a
good pass up ahead now Highmore shot
played a hit but knocked down by
Bailey it's time Oregon a backhand
and he'll be there to make that stop but
domey's got it on the top line we'll see
tomorrow in Toronto my gut feeling is at
some point they're going to for sure got a
piece of that nylander with a really good
chance to tie this up looks like there's
been some gomi nylander chemistry in this
first game together Riley holds the zone
another way final five seconds as it
comes back Lila that pass for Neil
Andrew Connell came over in the Ottawa
Senators Whitley first preseason game